Begin dictation, Captain's log.
We've been submerged for
weeks and are only now
seeing the first signs
of the Sargasso Sea.
There are far more baby sea
turtles here than I expected
and the Sargassum seaweed is a singular
almost yellowish shade of
green, and especially thick.
I've sent my cameras out to explore.
End dictation.
(playful music)
The Sargasso Sea is located here.
Zoom out a little bit.
It's the only sea in the
world that is not defined
by any land boundaries but
instead by ocean currents.
And it's known for its endemic
and anomalous seaweed.
(playful music)
This is Sargassum.
There is nearly 10 million
tons of it floating
on the sea's surface as this
seaweed has no root system.
You might recognize it
as it often washes up
on Caribbean beaches.
Many scientists call the
Sargasso Sea a nursery
in the open ocean because
it provides food and shelter
for many of the Atlantic Ocean's infants.
Most common are baby
Loggerhead sea turtles
who, after hatching, swim here to mature.
Young eels, shrimp, crabs,
mahi-mahi and marlins
also maturate here in the Sargasso.
Sacré bleu, what's that?
That thing floating there?
(sighs) It's plastic.
God do we hate plastic.
The Sargasso Sea is also home
to the North Atlantic Garbage Patch.
Trash from around the planet gathers here
thanks to multiple competing currents.
It's a human-made maritime disaster.
- That's why we only use
biodegradable plastic
on this submarine and no straws.
(soft instrumental music)
- Look Captain, I think one of the infants
has taken a liking to the ship.
So he has Bryan, so he has.
(soft music)